today we're uncovering a 500 million
dollar Ponzi scheme called Trader's
domain in part one we exposed a web of
scammers we found an ongoing government
investigation but as I spoke to victims
I realized there was someone behind the
curtains controlling it all
and that's when I find out there's this
one guy named dead who's making all the
trades and he's running this Ponzi
scheme we now learn of this Savant that
is The Man Behind Traders domain and so
this is the first time I ever hear the
name Ted safranco and I'm like who the
freak is Ted who's Ted that is the
multi-million dollar question and I
decided the best place to look for
answers was starting with the victims
welcome to part two my understanding of
who Ted sofranco was at the time I
invested was an experienced uh Trader
he's a Master Trader with relationships
like this all over the world and he was
internationally known and respected very
credible Wall Street Trader I know
that's bad to you know judge a book I
was covered like judge a book off of
their cover but you know you just look
like you know like a normal guy like a
Wall Street Trader you know he like he
didn't seem like the type of guy that
would mess you over
but looking into his real past
everything showed the opposite he didn't
work on Wall Street he got to start in
2016 when he was the student of a 23
year old get rich quick Guru on
Instagram named Nino koroff we know this
because of a testimonial he filmed hi
everyone my name is Ted I've been
working around right now with Nino for
probably about six months really what I
did is for 2016 what I tried to do is I
really wanted to set myself up nice
being a little bit older I've been
working for many years now almost 15
years I wanted to have a lifestyle
change I wanted to get into something
different to give myself a better
opportunity in life and literally I went
through social media I found you know on
Instagram I saw a laughed actually
because I saw him with his Lambo and all
his fun stuff and me being as old as I
am now I mean you know 37 years old 36
years old I couldn't really fathom how
somebody was doing what they were doing
at such a young age wow the answer of
course to Ted's question is is that nino
was scamming people with get rich quick
courses and Ted soon figured this out he
started his own grift called the Forex
family course which eventually led to
the launch of his very own Forex
brokerage called Trader's domain Ted
said that it would be non-manipulated as
opposed to most of the scammy brokerages
of the time and with his business
partner David negus they opened their
doors in 2018. I found this out because
I talked to the roommate at the time who
witnessed everything so my name is
Jonathan sametta I was roommates with
David negus at the start of 2018 pretty
much for the whole duration of the year
and I witnessed the Inception of Traders
domain from the beginning it was
basically a run out of the spare bedroom
of our house that's right we have an
eyewitness who saw the beginning of this
and what he told me is that Trader's
domain was originally selling themselves
as one of the good guys Forex has a lot
of
in the industry I'm sure a lot of people
are aware of that and there's a lot of
Brokers that have bad reputations you
know with doing Shady dealings Ted and
Dave started this operation under the
premise of the good guy in honesty and
being for the little guy sort of thing
someone you could trust which everybody
bought the Ted did have a a good
reputation in the community the way they
did this was they described themselves
as an a-book brokerage which I didn't
really understand at the time but
basically means they were one of the
legitimate ones can you just explain
really briefly what the difference
between a buck and bbook are so a book
your orders are direct to the market and
B book basically the broker takes the
opposite side of your trade so when you
lose money they win because most most
Traders lose so a lot of a lot of a lot
of work to just go people because they
make money off the trainer they're not
you're not your mark your orders aren't
actually going to the market it's just
the broker basically Shannon you okay to
summarize what he said real quick
because it's important Forex Brokers
which are a book it just means that your
trades are real be booking is when the
trades are kept in-house and things can
be faked they can be messed with and
this is why Ted said that his brokerage
was able he couldn't scam you and he
claimed this repeatedly but the question
is is that true with stories of changing
trades I wasn't so sure and then all of
a sudden
everything magically got erased and they
said oh the server is refreshed we had
to refresh the servers like that somehow
changed all the trades right and not
only were the stories Shady when I asked
the roommate about it he told me about a
very strange conversation he overheard I
was in my room one day and I overheard a
conversation and I thought I caught
something about B booking switching
people from a book to bbook and so I
asked Dave about it and he blatantly
said to me he's like he's like yeah he's
like if people are going to be losing we
might as well be both we're just leaving
money on the table it was kind of a
shock to me because that's you know kind
of went against everything that they had
sort of built this platform on so I just
didn't didn't really know how to take
that but I just took it for what it was
wow if this is true this means their
whole story is fake
claiming this is a pretty huge
accusation and I didn't want to do it on
the word of just one person because it
would mean that everything was built on
lies and fraud so I wanted more proof so
to do this I set up a Discord channel to
investigate Trader's domain and invited
all the victims to come share with me
what they had found and soon many of
them started sharing evidence including
a document which they said would prove
that they were be booking these people
showed me an invoice from a platform
called B2 broker addressed to Traders
domain FX which had a very important
line item quote minimum monthly payment
for the use of B book service why would
Trader's domain need to pay for a B book
service if they were a book now of
course we also need to talk about who is
B to broker they call themselves a white
label solution for brokerages and
exchanges which simply means they sell a
brokerage product that you can slap your
name on and it appears that this is
exactly what tetsufranco did which means
that the back end of Trader's domain and
what Ted is even selling is just a
rebranded product so we'll put feed a
broker on the board over here because
they're going to be key to understanding
this whole scam because as I found more
of these invoices I realized beta broker
may have helped facilitate this whole
thing all apparently for the low low
price of a thousand dollars a month for
this fee now what these several invoices
do is not only corroborate the story The
Roommate was telling us about be booking
it means that the trades and the crazy
returns are all likely fake it was all a
fraud based on a software Ted himself
never even built and of course now the
question is okay if the trades are fake
where did the money go because the
investment money was very much real even
if the trades were fake we know for a
fact that over a hundred million dollars
was invested based on the cftc's
estimate but based on what I have I
think it's significantly more either way
we're talking about an extremely large
amount of cash so it had to go somewhere
I mean we know from our first episode
that a lot of it went to this company
called CCAP Holdings but what happened
after that as I began to ask myself this
question I was contacted by an anonymous
source who found out that I was
investigating as I said I had made it
public at that point and they told me
they had a friend who might know
something more something that could
quote show B book activities money
laundering and fake invoices they asked
if I was interested of course I was and
when this friend got in touch they
claimed to have literally 2 000 plus
files and documents on Trader's domain I
was a little skeptical at first but when
the files showed up even I was surprised
[Music]
it took me weeks to go through all the
documents
but eventually
the pattern started to emerge
[Music]
the more I pulled on the threads the
more I realized
this was all connected
all right I think I get it I think I
understand how Traders domain took in
money if you look at our old
understanding of the company we had the
basics but we're missing several things
okay it starts with the sponsors they
were micro celebrities or influential
people who were paid very well to bring
in investors money and the more you
brought in the more you were paid which
was actually explained to me by a
sponsor who had 10 million dollars
underneath him so you've got 10 million
under you that's locked up how many does
the guy above you have he won't even
tell me but Millions he was getting like
probably half a million a month just in
payouts a lot I was doing well out there
I was getting paid about 20 30 000 a
month all right so these sponsors would
get a cut of the money that they brought
in which meant that they went out and
flexed on social media to bring in more
clients some bragged about Yachts some
invited people to to DM them for 10
percent monthly Roi deals either way
once the victims were on the hook they
would be instructed to go one of two
payment routes the first option was Cash
they would wire money to a us-based bank
like CCAP Holdings with a generic memo
that said services and definitely not
Forex or Investments because that would
trigger red flags and once word went out
that the wire had been sent before the
money even got their Traders domain
would immediately credit them on the
back end with fake money which we know
from interviews I did he would credit my
account with them ever having any money
before I ever gave them money you know
what I mean so the numbers were there
before you ever got before I ever paid
for anything so that day I get a
Trader's domain confirmation and it
shows up in my Trader's domain half a
million dollars sitting in my account
the next day Chase calls me and they go
home we just want to verify this as you
and I'm like oh you haven't released the
wire oh oh my God so they had accredited
your account before the money had ever
hit yeah before the money had ever hit
all right but if the money on Trader's
domain was fake where did the real money
go well I believe they had a money
laundering operation to get the money
offshore this is based on a series of
invoices I was given showing money being
sent from onshore Banks head to Franco
David negus 10 Tran controlled like say
capital and then they would send that to
Offshore companies shell companies which
were very suspicious for example we
found invoices sending a hundred
thousand dollars to a company called
safe seal technology
why in another one they sent a million
dollars to discover tour plus now this
one in particular had a website and if
you go to discover tourplus.com they
claim to be a travel agency but there's
nothing to actually buy I tried booking
my own vacation which I desperately need
at this point because I'm way too deep
in this investigation but none of the
links would let me book so this website
appears to just be a front for funneling
millions of dollars offshore besides who
even pays a million dollars to a travel
agency if you're a Forex Investment
Company especially does that multiple
times of course the alternate
explanation is that the reason you might
send money from a shell company in the
U.S to an offshore shell company is to
launder that money because then you can
now declare that million dollars the
travel agency took in the result of a
bustling business instead of fraud
now that's my theory but we have dozens
of these invoices which seem to confirm
it and you might expect that this was
the main way Trader's domain moved large
chunks of cash but you'd be wrong
because in 2023 laundering money through
banks is like communicating with smoke
signals instead of text messages no the
real way to launder money has changed
today it's crypto so this brings us to
option two of how to move money crypto
is the main way Trader's domain moved
money it was perfect for them and it was
the main way they circumvented
regulation recall at the beginning of
this show I told you that offshore
companies couldn't solicit U.S investors
but Traders domain told people that up
front they said quote Trader's domain
does not solicit U.S clients however
they would claim underneath that quote
just a note we have crypto accounts
available which is sort of like saying
hey we don't let in U.S clients through
the front door but just a note we have a
back door because when you went to their
website to sign up I kid you not as
country of origin you could select your
country as the country of crypto which
unsurprisingly some people actually did
uh one of the early things that felt
weird to me is that you couldn't
register as a US citizen on his website
side it was crypto you had to go and has
a crypto user I can still show you on my
account where I'm listed as a crypto
user and not a US citizen that is
clearly a
but the reason it matters is not that
they circumvented regulation people do
that all the time it's the scale this
was all happening on this wasn't a few
dollars this is hundreds of millions I
mean a single one of their payment
processors in crypto complained in a
recent lawsuit that the founder believed
that quote the Trader's domain is
clearly a Ponzi scheme they have moved
over 50 million dollars in
cryptocurrency and U.S currency directly
to the Trader's domain systems not only
that a different payment processor also
had their transaction data with Traders
domain leaked to us with the help of a
blockchain intelligence company called
Crystal blockchain we traced even more
money that had come in according to them
roughly 450 million went into Traders
domain and that combined with the 50
million from that other crypto payment
processor is where we arrive to our 500
million dollar estimate now bear in mind
this is just crypto this is not talk
talking about Fiat here and this is real
money that went in not fake Ponzi games
and at this point in the investigation
I'm feeling pretty confident we have two
really big things the first is that the
scale of this thing is huge probably
bigger than even the government believes
it is but I also feel extremely
confident we have proof of Fraud and the
only thing left to do is confront the
man behind it all Ted safranco
and this is also the thing that I've
been putting off doing the whole time to
be honest because the entire
investigation as I spoke to people I was
warned not to reach out because Ted was
well known for going after anyone who
went after his brokerage he allegedly
said things like quote you want to come
after my brokerage you have a death wish
in messages and I am going to put a
bounty on your head
there were a lot more of these and of
course he also famously threatened
people on video I take a flight to the
UK right now and just show up and curb
stomp their heads yeah I get arrested so
what I win because they're dead so yeah
the guy is kind of a psycho so I was
very nervous about doing this and so I
decided to go to the bar and get me a
little bit of liquid courage
come on coffee you've been sitting here
for two hours are you gonna do it or not
give me give me this one more shot okay
and then I'll do it
here goes nothing
come on Ted
I bet you he's not even gonna answer
the come on
to an automatic voice message
I knew it and that settles that
you want another drink
I guess so
you humans are such odd creatures you
were nervous about calling yet you seem
upset he didn't answer I was concerned I
mean but once I was committed I I don't
know it just feels a little
anti-climactic I guess maybe it's for
the best not everything has a Hollywood
ending
you do the best you can and sometimes
you have to enjoy a consolation prize
what's that how about a drink with a
friend wait I thought you couldn't drink
take the shot coffee all right
I've been watching you high
I just closed my eyes
I've known for a while
[Music]
my dear if you keep pulling that bread
uh hello
before we continue obviously I've spoken
to my Council we we know about your
YouTube channel now we reviewed it I
mean there's really nothing of substance
on there to be honest I think it's more
of a glorified click bait Channel I'm in
chats right now on telegram he's still
in there actively saying that he's
trading you can think anything you want
you can turn around and say that I am
that is such a chicken response from a
total coward no accountability at all
nobody knows anything about his wife
because they don't have the resources
that I have my resources can find out
every little thing about you
you will see the amount of Destruction I
leave
[Music]
thank you